so i'm here with marcos and this
experiment we're doing was like hey I
said having pictures on auto rough so I
maybe should have videos of people nice
thanks so so what do you do here time
and designer here at the Khan Academy
that actually goes to different ways one
and I'm doing like software design and
that's kind of touchy on the exercise
framework that we have right now I've
been focused a lot on trying to make
more interactive exercises easier to
develop and there's a framework that I'm
building for that that I'm open sourcing
at the same time what do you mean by
more interactive exercises right now a
lot of our says are kind of present you
the question it's like what is the sum
of blah blah blah or what are what's
complete the square and it asks you this
very simple one-step computation a lot
of stuff that I'm looking at is how to
make exercises that let you follow a
larger kind of narrative or enough
problem solving so in that case I'd be
like let's say you are this tall here
and your shadow is this feet long and
then you know your friend is over you
know maybe 35 nautical miles away and
his shadow is this long you know given
that what do you expect the
circumference of the earth to be oh yes
and so you know you re creating like the
greatest you're doing all the greats
scientific discoveries but you know
they're not very hard if you know the
kind of basic concepts in there you just
need someone to guide you along the way
yeah yeah a lot of what I've been
thinking about is developing a framework
and actually developing the framework
not just thank you okay right right for
making that happen and your your your
background is pretty interesting when
you start it off at MIT CS major you're
actually math with CF Matt would see if
you will not like your diet six are you
died six is quarters computer science at
MIT computer so it's kind of a the
Matthew yeah Peter sighs really is mad
yeah yeah yes day and end and then you
decided that that was not enough well i
mean i think i was i was pleasantly
surprised with how that had gotten but
I'm what I was really focused on at the
time was sinking my education in the
context of making text books textbooks
on out say what you will about them
looking at me dying out or whatever I
mean I still believe I so bleak but I
want to make really good textbook yeah
well we we got a textbook say this
textbook books and led some signs with
ya and so I actually ended up doing
after i'm teaching the neck web design
for about a year and a half was applying
to design school
and the whole purpose behind that was
actually to make a really awesome
textbook so I didn't even realize this
doesn't even come out in the interview
you this is me you wanted to like
reinvent textbooks yeah I wanted to
actually make like the coolest textbook
and like in my like after like being
design school making my handmade books
for example I was like yeah four by six
little book would be really sweet and I
was like really excited jazzed about
this and and then you know as I started
in 2007 to 2009 you know it's like you
have the ipad the iphone all these
technological advances just happen while
I'm in grad school only you have to
rethink this a little so i got this
design degree but rumor is d from
risking a serious design school so I
went mess around there so i did my grad
program in design and i got a lot of the
basics I you know learned all the
fundamentals typography design layout I
got really attuned to that and then
focused my energies again thinking about
you know like how do i create you know
reusable design systems and i ended up
being my thesis was these comedy CS
majors were there you know what actually
what I left there was one and a half
more what so actually it's um it's an
up-and-coming thing ya know I think more
I think that's actually a good
combination in fact i think probably
design should be a critical part of yeah
and more engineers I mean exactly i did
a lot of what i noticed at least was
that there were a lot of there's a lot
of similarity i mean you have like the
Christopher Alexander design patterns
thinking that systems thinking actually
is like massive in graphic design yeah
but it was also you know something that
was huge in like you know the design
pattern movement also in CS yeah a lot
of like a happy medium and so why did
you decide to come here or how do you
how do you even find out about what we
were my gosh I saw like a lattice
multiplication video I think I saw it on
reddit and I was like this is ridiculous
and I was like watching him and a good
or bad way well at first I saw it I was
like I have never heard of last
publication like it looks like I saw
leagues its massive list of links and it
someone had a link to it yeah I was a
little skeptical and then like for some
reason I like finished watching the
video I'm like whoa that's interesting
like I actually like this is one of our
video yes and I'd know there was good
ridiculous yeah it was a good read okay
like at first
incredibly skeptical i was just like no
no no I'd done my like you know my
little concentration education secondary
school and I was like I don't know yeah
and but you know it's like you find
yourself actually finishing the video
you know and you're like oh like there's
something here like there's actually
something there I didn't actually see
you guys again for another like a year
and a half I was like working in CMU and
doing my own thing at that time what was
your own thing oh oh like you know I was
doing like freelance work at the same
time I was also working with the HCI
institute human so see Amelia Carnegie
Mellon yeah Carnegie Mellon is a human
computer interaction to telka with Laura
davish and Rob amazing group they're
doing a really interesting work with
team-based dynamics online and when one
vote and so what were you doing I was
actually like kind of staff designer and
then like doing some CS work on the side
so like doing a lot of refactoring of
the code base and making sure that we
could reproducibly perform these
experiments on these you know like a
couple thousand facebook users every
week ok ok so we were running these like
kind of like massive experiment since I
learned even though I wasn't doing like
the straight up like experiment design
kind of Oz most a lot of that stuff
while I was there and then why you're so
so I interrupted your story how did you
find out about what we're doing or so I
started seeing I mean I think then
actually been Caymans is really good
about we're like nine bends in the
appendix very specific so then Caymans
actually did a pretty good job like post
count hat can use every once in a while
and then I was like man like this is
totally changed from the time that I saw
the first time like I think it had
already gone through that one design
iteration like I was pretty interesting
and then I saw you guys were actually
get post movie sounds like this is
perfect yeah like you know what could be
more perfect than this yeah and so I
just threw my hat in the ring and you
know there's a rest is right what is
this history and hopefully will the
future too yeah and and and you know
what what's been has any as it has you
know what's been some what were you
hoping to do here and has it been
surprising is it been just as you
expected or you know I think so actually
when I first got here I think I even
wrote that in my cover letter I was like
you know I don't know what I will do
when I get here but I'm like really
excited to do stuff here I had no idea
that I'd be working on interactive
exercises i think that was like a
glimmer in my eye
you know Street out of design school I
mean straight out like you know a year
and a half out of design school I
thought I'd probably be doing like
business cards and logos and yeah that's
like a kind of stupid stuff really you
thought I mean you know I mean you're
capable yeah more than this of course
I'm capable I mean I think that is for
my design skills I think in my mind I
kind of we expected to spend like you
know a couple months doing that and I
ended up just diving on in you know like
thinking about new features thinking
about ways to make the site more
friendly and overall I mean like it it
was a huge like mine shipped in like the
term of like impact and scale and the
ability to do something really cool in
education I mean like it was just like
we did this thing with David one of our
awesome interns and it was just you know
like how can we make this week bar more
fun you know it's like we play with just
these very simple visual forms and like
thinking like what happens when you lose
your streak bar like what does that feel
like and a lot of these are like very
design ish things that we were probing
but you know we ended up coming up with
her very and he actually deserves most
of the credit I mean you can't with a
very stunning a model for kind of making
that more interesting in a more
appropriate way of engaging and
measuring our proficiency who like like
deep design questions you can actually
measure like it were corrected it like
exactly you know like does it feel
better to you know like drop down to
something like to drop down to some
arbitrary amount and start over again to
feel better to drop to a percentage
which represents our actual belief and
how far you're doing you know which of
these mornings how do we measure our
actual belief and how you're doing
exactly and a lot of that you know I
mean we're questions of would it feel
better as you're gaining proficiency you
know you had a kind of like a moving
indicator or something that kind of like
moves along and animates and it was born
out of these like kind of very playful
ideas and it actually ended up evolving
into something that was very more much
more rigorous than kind of like the joy
of you like one back and forth that we
were having initially we were sketching
it out all right so all right and what
do you hope where do you hope this goes
well you know I mean I think recently
I've been spending a lot of time
thinking about this kind of disease
interactive exercises and I actually
feel like I'm going closer to my
original idea for this text
book I mean a Senate sounds kind of
silly but it feels like what I'm doing
and the work that I'm working on gets me
closer to designing these portable
textbooks which now I mean portable
because we have like phones you know
your iPad and whatnot but things that
are engaging that are lightweight and
that let you kind of dive in at any
level just kind of a or maybe do things
that textbooks couldn't do well I mean I
think Tex books are capable of a lot
I'll be I'll be honest you know maybe we
disagree no no I do think I firmly
believe in the higher the textbook but I
think for the things that for the kind
of reactive exercises that we can pull
off and for the ability to ask questions
that are experimentally you can you can
actually place a little experimental
test bed in one of these exercises and I
think that's powerful I mean I think
that's huge right like being able to see
a goal you know that I got the answer
what happens if I had done this you know
and seeing that there's an exercise that
is able to adapt to that way of right I
think that's huge and right if and that
would have been hard with the
traditional check with it oh yeah I mean
like you know you end up having to build
up all of this like you know scaffolding
basically in paper which I mean again
totally fine right but it's the time
that you can lose to you know being
unable to explore and play with tweaking
values I mean I think that's awesome
very cool so